okay let's move on to your late teens
and 20s so here we go you started acting
in college in Los Angeles right UCLA how
did you end up going to New York what
made the move when did you make the move
well I was in a musical comedy Workshop
uh at UCLA and we did a scene I did a
scene from Annie Get Your Gun as a final
uh that they were going to grade us on
it but there was an audience and
afterwards this gentleman and his wife
came up to me and they said we liked you
very much and what do you want to do
with your life and I said well someday I
want to go to New York and be on the
stage and to be a musical comedy like
Mary Martin and Ethel Merman and yeah
the gentleman said well why aren't you
there now and I said well you know we
were cost money yeah and we were poor
yeah and I said but someday I hope to
save up enough you know and he said I'll
lend you the money
and so he did he's a complete stranger
yeah and I thought what is it is he
kidding and his wife said no she'll then
he lent me
five uh one thousand dollars and he said
pay it back when you can within five
years
stipulations don't ever reveal my name
you must use the money to go to New York
on
and if you are successful you must
promise to help other people out too
what a beautiful lesson right off the
bat
so I did I I took the money I went to
New York and I
got lucky
and uh I think Talent had something to
do with it yeah
I paid him back that's incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]